vera hier l'ambassadeur ukrainien au
royaume uni s'est exprimé et le
porte-parole de la présidence russe a
réagi ce matin
bonjour grégory oui effectivement
l'ukraine continue de dominer l'ordre du
jour à l'international le porte parole
du kremlin dmitri peskov a notamment
réagi à la déclaration de l'ambassadeur
ukrainien à londres quant à une
possibilité pour le cren de s'engager à
ne pas faire partie de le temps afin
d'éviter une guerre avec la russie
dmitri peskov a reconnu qu'il était peu
probable qu'il s'agisse là d'un
changement de cap dans la politique
craignait le bureau du président de
l'admr zelensky affectivement sommet
l'ambassadeur à s'expliquer sur ses
propos mais a affirmé que la non
extension de l'otan en ukraine aurait
répondu à une demande majeure de la
russie je vous propose d'écouter
sans aucun doute un rejet par l'ukraine
de l'idée de rejoindre l'otan fixe et
est confirmée d'une manière ou d'une
autre constituerait certainement une
démarche qui contribuerait de manière
importante à la formulation d'une
réponse plus significative aux
préoccupations russes
tenu des tractations diplomatiques au
sujet des garanties de sécurité ces
propositions émises par la russie fin
2021 au sujet de l' architecture de la
sécurité en europe selon dmitri peskov
l'essentiel est que le dialogue continu
avec les états unis même si les
relations sont actuellement loin d'être
au beau fixe écoutez
ce jour
il est évident qu'il va y avoir des
années d'âpres confrontation et que
chacun aura à coeur de maintenir ses
positions lors de négociations à l'issue
incertaine en ce qui concerne les
questions conceptuelles pour nous les
etats unis continuent d'ignorer nos
préoccupations notamment ce qui concerne
le point soulevé par le président
poutine sur les garanties de sécurité
donc la situation n'est pas encourageant
nous espérons en tant que personne
raisonnable nous nous préparons au pire
mais nous continuons d'espérer le
meilleur nous espérons donc que ces
rares voies de dialogue nous permettront
de constater une certaine réciprocité
chez nos adversaires et une volonté de
trouver des solutions et pas pour cocher
une case mais bien pour que nos intérêts
soient prises en compte
dans
le crâne sera également au menu des
pourparlers entre vladimir poutine et le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz qui
après sa visite à kiev aujourd'hui se
rendra demain à moscou
merci verhaeghe hoffman pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou donc en
russie